Il y a 20 ans, le monde est tombé dans la merde,
des villes ont érigé des murs pour
se protéger et ont jeté les criminels
pour qu'ils puissent se battre pour ce qui restait,
mais il y a d'humbles [ __ ] comme
moi qui livrent des marchandises d'une ville fortifiée
à une autre, c'est là que les voitures et les
armes arrivent
donc si je suis ici, alors la sortie est oh ils
ont un Foot Locker
bienvenue à New San Francisco Je veux
t'engager ramasser un colis le ramener
Je peux réaliser chacun de tes souhaits alors
John que souhaites-tu pour les toilettes  papier
à appliquer je pense que je peux mieux
répondre d'
accord Evelyn livrons ce
colis
c'est impoli de ne pas se présenter
avant de tirer une arme sur quelqu'un
si vous posez l'arme je vous
déposerai aussi près que possible de l'endroit où vous '  re
va c'est juste calme elle ne parle pas
[ __ ] mange beaucoup de merde tu n'as aucune
idée de ce que le sud-est même les gens
qui essaient de ramener la loi sont
dangereux C'est notre terre ce sont toutes
des routes et ils vont devoir passer
par Vegas
au-dessus  pas de règles Vegas John salut tout le monde
je n'ai jamais vu quelqu'un couper une
tête humaine et l'attraper aussi bien que ça
Je suis venu ici
[Musique]
ça ne m'est jamais arrivé avant vraiment
ouais
oh mec
[Musique]
c'est DMV quoi de neuf  cris cool de la ligne rouge